You know, your eyes go through a lot. Every day with things like reading and dim light, too much screen time, that happens to me all the time. Bright sun in your eyes when you're driving. Even nighttime driving can cause eye strain. So, yeah, we're putting our eyes through a lot. So it's important to take care of them and monitor their health with regular eye exams. Check their healthy with an eye exam at spec savers from $99, which includes an OCT eye health scan that helps to detect eye. and health conditions at early stages.
To find a location near you and book an eye exam with an OCT scan from $99, visit specksavers. I exams are provided by independent optometrists. Prices may vary by location. We've all been there, the unexpected hosting panic. Like when the watch party finally makes it out of the group chat, but you volunteered to host. And suddenly you need snacks, drinks, dips, cups, and all the other party essentials no one planned for. With Instacart, you can get all those groceries delivered in as fast as 60 minutes. No extra errands for you. One quick order for everyone. That way, everything shows up right on time,
making hosting easy and making it look like you had it planned all along. Download the Instacart app today and get no markups at select retailers. Fees and in-store offer exclusions apply. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. There you guys.
We wanted to take a break in our The Paper rewatch to share something really fun with you. We had a great time talking with Ed Helms on his podcast, Snap-Foo. Yes, Ed has a podcast and it's a lot of fun. Like Anch said, it's called Snafu, and we were his guest last year, but in case you missed it, we wanted to bring it to our feed today. And let me tell you, if you love deep dives, you are going to love snafu. Here's what happens. On each episode, Ed does a deep dive of a snafu moment from history. So we discussed that, but then, of course, we also talk a lot about our time on the office together.
You know, it was very funny to me that the snafu moment that Ed picked to share with us takes place on a boat. And Angela, I can't believe that we did not bring up the fact that his character on the office, Andy, loves boats. I know. I mean, what a missed opportunity. Andy Bernard loves boats. But he also had several snafu moments on his family boat, the old 43-foot tart and sloop. And we're going to talk about things falling in the ocean. Andy had a snafu.
Was it his phone or his laptop? Remember it? It just slides in the ocean. Yes. Well, listen, it was really fun to catch up with Ed. So we hope you enjoy listening to us on his podcast. And next week, we'll be back for an all-new episode of Office Lady 6.0 as we continue are the paper breakdown. Now I know why they call it broken arrows. Because when you say, you know what, we have 32 broken arrows. You're like, oh, if you say we have 32 lost nuclear weapons, you're like, wait, stop?
What? Say again. Euphemisms make hard things a lot easier. Hey, I'm Ed Helms, host of Snafu, a show about history's greatest screw-ups. Today, I am joined by two of my all-time favorite humans on the planet, Angela Kinsey and Jenna Fisher. Of course, you know them as Angela Martin and Pam Beasley from the office, where we spent many years. Making each other chuckle both on and off camera. These days, they co-host the wildly beloved Office Ladies podcast, where they deep dive into every episode, every single episode of the office with their very own distinct brand of insight, warmth, heart, and hilarity.
Angela and Jenna, I am so psyched. You're here. Hi, Ed. Hi, Ed. Yeah, it's so good to see you. I'm getting jazz hands right now because we've got video going. I just want to jazz it up a little. Jazz it up.
All right. Let me ask a very, I think very pressing question that all of our listeners and viewers are probably wondering right now, which is how much do you miss working with me on a daily basis? Oh, my gosh. I miss the office a lot. I know. I mean, we spend our days. Our job now is watching the show. And it always just brings up so many memories of working together.
And you know how many bloopers there are. Oh, yeah. There's so many because we would just laugh all day together. That's what we did. Ed, I miss, I miss being silly with you. Like, we would get so silly. Like, I would walk past you and we would just make up a new noise. Like pewing, wing, whing, whing.
Like, p.oing, wing. Oh, my God. It's like all the stuff off camera, the life experience of that whole time. period, which was just had this kind of larger umbrella feeling of like, wow, we're all part of something really great. And that's like super special. But then we're also having these really mundane, lovely moments on the set just talking about each other's lives and families and like, I don't know, just the little, those little quiet moments or sitting at our trailers like waiting for a camera set up. or it's like that that's I think something that like fans don't always understand is that like our experience of making the show is actually this whole tapestry of mundane small moments of just
experiencing each other. I mean, it's an intimacy. Yeah. You know, of togetherness, of constant togetherness. Yeah. And I think if I could go back and relive a moment, like if, you know, I got a genie in a bottle and I could use a wish, it would be to go back and shoot a conference room scene all day. Because when we would see those on the script or on the call sheet and we would be like,
oh, God, we got to be in the conference room. It's going to be a slog. Day. All day. But those were the days that created the moments you're talking about, Ed. Totally. Those little laughs, the shares, the sweatiness together, all of it. I also think because we weren't on a huge lot, you know, there wasn't.
No distraction. You know, people didn't walk off to a commissary. We were just all in this little bubble, this tiny space where we got to be creative together. It kind of reminded me a little bit of that energy you have in your early days with your improv group or your one-act play, because there was no one else. There was no shiny object to go off and look at. It was just us. Like, I loved it when you would play your banjo and Creed would bring in his guitar and we'd hang out in the parking lot, you know? Yeah, and it's funny you bring up those conference room scenes because those were particularly special because most of the time we're not all together, right? Most of the time, we're just doing little scenes with like one or two other characters.
And that's the bulk of our work. But then the table read was always a special moment. Every Tuesday morning was the table read of next week's script. Or two weeks. I forget the timing. Oh, it was one week. It was one week. One week.
It was less than a week's notice. Yeah. But those are the moments, those and some of those conference room scenes were like, that's where everybody's together. Like everybody's. And those had a really special energy, like just a little buzz to them. And when, and like you said, when they were all day long, that's, and they get a little dull and they start to slow down. Everybody's trying to just hang in there. that's like some of the just most human hangout.
Ed, you had a really unique experience joining the show because you actually joined in Stanford. So you didn't start off in the Dunder Mifflin bullpen of the Scranton Dunder Mifflin bullpen. And then you came over. What was that like for you to kind of like soft launch into the show? Like you worked with John, you worked with Rashida, you worked with Chip. Yeah. Well, sorry, Jenna.
I'll be asking the questions today. I forgot his podcast we were doing. No, I love the question. I always tell people, like, that was such a gentle entry for us because of exactly what you're saying. Like, you know, Rashida and I started at a time when the show was hot. It was season three, and you guys had already just kind of, like, created this incredible thing. And so we were intimidated, but also felt kind of so warmly welcomed, both by the writers and all of you. Everyone's energy was so lovely.
That's so sweet. It really could have gone the other way. I'm sure a lot of other shows, there's like more, it's more cutthroat or it feels more like, ah, the new people. Like, let's let them, they have to prove themselves. But I just felt so, like, all of my butterflies and anxiety just, washed out so quickly because everyone, all of you were so lovely right out of the gate, which is a testament to all of you and the vibe that got created. It was collaborative.
It was not competitive. Totally. There was not like a weird, like, ego competitiveness going on on that set, which was so great. Absolutely. Yeah. It was always, you know, we always say it was a real creative collaboration from the writer's room to the crew to the cast. We're all working together to create a product that we were proud of.
And I think, I mean, I think you feel that when you watch it. And I think that's why people keep enjoying it is you're seeing a group of people having a great time. There's a warmth there that's real. And I think that comes through the camera. All right. Well, first, this is something I ask all of my guests. Is there a moment in your own life, a mishap, a misunderstanding, a full-blown meltdown that would qualify as a snafu? I mean, I have one that immediately comes to mind.
What is it, lady? I had just moved from Indonesia to Dallas, Texas in the 80s. Okay, 1984. I had lived in Jakarta for 12 years. I didn't know what the heck an American high school vibe was. Oh, my God. And I was also a grade ahead in half my subjects. So I would go to the junior high for the first four classes.
then my mom would pick me up. I'd eat lunch in the car, driving to the high school. And I was like this tiny little thing and this big high school. I was such an outsider. And I really wanted to fit in. And I'm a freshman who's moved from Indonesia, who doesn't know, like, I'm supposed to get a perm and wear a bunch of eyeliner. I don't know that yet.
Yeah, Texas has a real, real specific high school vibe. especially in the 80s. 80s. 80s, Dallas. That's a vibe. Okay, first class of the day, English class, super hot dude behind me, like athletic dude. And I'm at my desk and my pencil on the desk rolls off to the right on the ground. I lean over to get it.
I don't calibrate my weight versus the wraparound desk weight. Oh, no. The whole thing flipped over on me. pinned me to the ground with my feet akimbo. And the hottie dude behind me is like, oh my gosh. It goes to pick me up. And they were like, your arm. And I'm fine.
I'm fine. I'm fine. And my arm, I thought I broke my arm. Does this story end with the hottie asking you out? Because you've also just described like every meat cute in a teen movie from the 80s. I'm going to tell you right now, those meat cutts are a lie. All right. You got a quick one, Jenna?
I do. So it's not a school snafu, but it's a teenage snafu. I had a big crush on one of the guys who lived in my neighborhood. And I kind of wanted to like just impress him, you know, like in that way where you want to peacock a little, maybe catch their eyes. So I had gotten this like new Esprit top. Do you remember Espray? Oh, yeah, of course. Very, very cool brand.
And loved a spree. Very proud of it. And I had like this special like matching ribbon for my hair. So I put this on. And my, my idea was that I'd go out and get the mail. So it would be a reason for me to like walk out. So I timed it out.
I like sat and like watched him arrive home. And I proudly walked out in my spree top. And I went, I looked in the mailbox and like, oh, there's nothing there. But you know, I'm really looking as if, you know, it's okay. And he is, he is. watching me, right? Like, it's, I caught his eye. I get inside.
My mom says, what are you doing? And I said, oh, nothing. I was just, I was just going to get the mail. And she said, sweetie, you're not wearing any pants. Oh, no. That's right. What? That's right.
I forgot. I was so into my espree top that I forgot to put on the bottoms of the outfit, y'all. Like any bottoms? I mean, I had on like undies. Undies, but I didn't have on pants. This is like I had on this like long. It was kind of like an Oxford shirt. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It hung down even past my underwear. Oh, this is very 80s. No, I was like, I was like Tom Cruise in, um, risky business. Just walking out in my big Oxford with no pants on. And then I hid in my house for the next four years and never spoke to him again. Oh, boy. I was so embarrassed. Those are some major snafews, you guys.
That's, yeah, that's big stuff. This one might be bigger. I hope so. Angela and Jenna, are you ready to dive into today's snafu? I'm so excited. I'm having a sip of my iced tea. All right. Get ready.
Get your popcorn. Ed, I love a snafu. I love you. I love this pod. So three of my favorite things are about to happen all at once. And I love Angela, my BFF. There you go. Four things.
This is just an abundance of riches right here. It is. Today, Snapu takes us aboard the USS Ticonderoga, a massive aircraft carrier stationed off the coast of Japan in 1965. This thing was built like it was auditioning for a Cold War action movie. Tough exterior, fighter jets everywhere, total mid-century badass. Picture of Don Draper and Maverick from Top Gun had a baby. and the baby was a boat. And it like chain smoked all the time.
Like that's what this aircraft carrier was like. Pure American military swagger. Unfortunately, that swagger was about to trip into a colossal face plant. So what happened was what is known in military circles as a broken arrow incident. Do either of you know what that term means? There was a movie called Broken Arrow. Yes. There was.
I don't. Do you know what the movie was about? It might get, it might help. Okay. I feel like a guy jumped off a train. Maybe that happened in that movie. But a broken arrow incident is that that's when we lose a nuclear device. Oh, my goodness.
I think the nuclear device was on the train. Yeah. Okay, yeah. Okay, whatever. Let go. Let it go, Angela. I feel like John Travolta was in that movie. I can't remember anything else about it.
But anyway, the term broken arrow, that refers to any time we lose a nuclear missile or a bomb or device of some sort. And it happens, it has happened throughout history, numerous, like way more than you want to know. I mean, enough times they had to have a code name for it. Well, losing a nuclear weapon sounds completely insane. And it is. But part of why I wanted to bring this story to you guys in particular is that it has kind of a familiar flavor, clashing personalities, baffling miscommunication, questionable leadership choices. Basically, this is a classic workplace comedy.
This is if Michael Scott was in charge. Yeah, yeah. And instead of cubicles, we're on a thousand foot warship in the middle of the Pacific Ocean. Instead of paper jams, we're dealing with hydrogen bombs. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Sometimes it can feel like everyone else has it all together. Their love life, even whether they're married or dating or dating. single, like they've got it figured out. But the truth is, I think we're all still figuring it out.
No matter where you are in your romantic journey, therapy is kind of great because you have someone to talk it out with, get advice from, kind of help you determine what you want and take some of that pressure off yourself. Yeah, and maybe to help unpack some elements of the past that might be holding you back, will better help therapists work according to a strict code of conduct. They are fully licensed in the U.S. and BetterHelp will offer you the therapist match commitment. You get a short questionnaire, you say your preferences, and they'll match you with someone. But guess what? If you don't like them, you can switch to a different therapist at any time. With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, having served over 5 million people globally.
Sign up and get 10% off at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's BetterH-E-L-P.com slash office ladies. What's up guys? I'm Candace Dillard Bassett, and you may know me from my time on the Real Housewives of Potomac or as a part of the latest cast of The Traders. And I'm Michael Arsino, author of The New York Times Bestseller, I Can't Date Jesus. On our podcast, Undomesticated, we don't just say the quiet parents out loud, we're putting it all in the kitchen table and inviting you into the chaos. If you're ready for bold takes, real talk, and a little fun, come join us. Listen to and follow Undomesticated and Odyssey Podcast available wherever you get your podcast. On December 5th, 1965, just off the coast of Japan's Ryuku Islands, U.S. naval officers were running through a routine training exercise called the crew cut on the USS Taekonduroga.
An A4E Skyhawk, an attack fighter jet, was being wheeled into the elevator to be taken up to the flight deck. So quick pause. Are you guys nervous flyers? I am not, but I will say that for some reason the idea of landing or taking off on an air. Aircraft carrier scares the bejesus out of me. It's like, I don't know if it's the tiny runway or just the fact that it's surrounded by water or that it's constantly moving or that there's like 30 people on deck just casually waving around glow sticks. Like it's a rave for fighter james. I just, this is very unchill vibes for me.
Also, like with the short runway, don't they have like a cable that catches the plane and jerks it back? I mean, if you need a cable to catch your plane on a. landing. I don't know. What if you missed the cable? I got invited to do something like that. There was like, they invited me to be like in a cockpit for like a special flying mission thing. Cool. And I was like, I don't need to read anymore.
Like, this is not going to go well for anyone. You're just going to have a lady throwing up on everyone. For this crew cut exercise, the pilot, Lieutenant Douglas Webster, was simply supposed to take off fly around for a bit and then land again, a routine drill to practice loading and unloading cargo. But almost immediately, things went off the rails. As the Skyhawk was being positioned on the elevator, it suddenly began rolling backward. The crew on the deck started waving frantically, shouting for Webster to hit the brakes. A few even ran behind the aircraft trying to stop it from rolling heroic, but not exactly
realistic. The Skyhawk was one of the Navy's lighter planes. but it still had a take off weight of 24,500 pounds. So this was not a rogue shopping cart. This is like a tank with wings, basically. Somehow, Webster didn't catch on to all the chaos going on around him. And in a split second, the Skyhawk rolled off the side of the carrier, tore through the safety netting, and vanished into the ocean. What would you do if you're a crew member on this flight?
deck and you're just like standing there watching this. Explitives. Some cursing. Who's getting fired? Someone's getting fired. Yeah, for sure. I would be like, we got to tell somebody. Have you ever like gone to sit down on the toilet and your phone's in your pocket and then it
falls in the toilet? Oh my God. That's my worst nightmare. That's never happened to me. Thank God. That's never, you've never dropped your phone in the toilet? No, I never have. Oh, my gosh.
I've done this before. I've never dropped your phone in a. swimming pool or something in a pool of water. That's what this is reminding me of. Okay. But every time I go into an airport bath, like the urinals in an airport, I'm just like, I pocket my phone for that exact reason. I'm so terrible.
Because if like my phone goes into like a public urinal, it's staying there. Like no, I ain't getting it out. It is done. Goodbye phone. I wonder if it was, because like when it dips, when it falls into the ocean, like, it's gone. Like it ain't, you can't see anything. And I just wonder if it went through anyone's head to just pull one of those like, like the crew on the deck is like where where's the plane? Somebody's like, what plane?
What are you talking about? What? What? Hmm? Plain? There was no plane? I'm not sure. There's other planes.
You know what? But there was no plane here. Here's the other play. How dare you? The confident. How dare you ask me that? You just got to come in with like full, the confident rebuttal. What?
How dare you? There was a plane here two minutes ago. No, there were what? What? I would know. I was standing here. My job was to stop it from rolling. So the crew sprang into action, calling nearby ships to launch a full search and rescue operation.
But it wasn't just about finding the beloved Lieutenant Douglas Webster, who was still inside the plane, as it's saying. Oh, my God. I didn't. Yeah. Yeah. There's a guy in the plane. We didn't know if he was still in the plane. He was in the plane.
I thought he was. Oh, no. Yeah. Oh, no. I know. Spoiler alert. He did not make it. Oh.
He was not recovered. That's terrible. I know. Was he the only crew member in the person in the plane? Yes. He's the only one who perished. Oh, my goodness. There was also something else on board.
A one megaton nuclear bomb. Yeah. For reference, that's 70 times more powerful than the bomb dropped on Hiroshima, which to put it in Dundermifflin terms is like someone misplacing a really important post-it note if that post-it note could also vaporize a city. So this whole enormous plane with the super-duper nuke and this poor man just go over the edge. Yes. They just go right over the edge.
And I love the term you just said super-duper nuke. It feels like it. I think that I believe that's the technical service. Yeah. Do you guys load the Super Doper Nuke? Oh, yeah. It's ready to go. So a frantic search followed.
But tragically, neither the pilot nor the aircraft was ever recovered. The only thing they found was his helmet bobbing alone on the surface of the ocean, which really since chills down your spine. So here's the thing. This was not just a casual cruise that the Ticonderoga was on. It had just wrapped up combat duty in Vietnam. and was en route to Japan for some much-needed rest and refueling. And that's when the inevitable cover-up begins. So let's break down the optics for a second.
The U.S. aircraft carrier, fresh from war, accidentally drops a nuclear bomb just off the coast of Japan, a country with, let's say, a very specific set of feelings about nuclear bombs. This is, again, it's 1965, so not too much time has passed. Oh, and just for some added detail, we had signed a treaty promising we wouldn't bring nukes anywhere near Japanese shores. So, yeah, this was not going to go over well. Was the ship more than 200 nautical miles off the coastline of Japan? Oh, my God, who are you? What kind of? This is a very specific question.
Well, I had just read that, I had just read that. I just read that every country is responsible and has ownership of the first 200 nautical miles off their shoreline. So if this was within Japan's 200 nautical miles, that is a very big breach because you're not an open ocean. Yeah. I believe it was well within Japanese jurisdiction. It was a very bad look. And so, of course, to avoid the bad look, the Navy tried to cover it up. They zipped it up, tight-lipped.
But as we all know, military secrets have a way of slinking into the public zeitgeist eventually. Are you guys good secret keepers? Are you trustworthy? Lock it up. Lock it up. Yeah, but not, this is not a secret I could keep. Yeah. I would be a whistleblower.
I'm good at keeping your secrets or Angela's secrets. or friends and family secrets, my own secrets. But I'm not going to keep your, we lost a nuclear weapon in the ocean secret for you if you're the military. Like, I'm going to be the lady who is writing a report on that. The Navy was spectacularly or perhaps frighteningly able to conceal this incident for over 15 years. It wasn't until 1981 that the Pentagon disclosed the incident. The Washington Post reported about it.
in a mere three sentences buried in a nuclear accidents report. However, the folks at the Pentagon also did not bother explaining the details of where exactly the bomb was. They first stated that the bomb was more than 500 miles from land. Vague much? They also assured everyone that the bomb posed no danger since it was 16,000 feet underwater. But in 1989, the Environmental Group Group Group, Greenpeace, alongside naval expert William Arkin, exposed more naval documents, revealing that the bomb was dropped only 70 miles off the coast of the Ryuku Islands, as opposed to the 500, they had said before. They also pointed out that this incident violated Japan's strict anti-nuclear policies and exposed some serious Navy secrets about nuclear weapons in Vietnam.
With no other choice, the Pentagon finally admitted the whole trip. about this gigantic snafu in a statement that same year in 1989. Did this create a diplomatic issue for the United States and the Japanese government? Yeah. In 1989? Yeah. For sure. It feels like these international incidents are, there's always some measure of just sort of posturing
of like, we have to respond this way because protocol demands it of us. And so we must make these statements and we must say these things. And we must say that we're outraged. And then the U.S. must respond with their, like, diplomatic explanation and acceptance of responsibility. It's like, it's so choreographed all these things. It's very wild how it all works out. And then I always wonder, like, does anyone actually take this personally?
If, like, Japan is expressing outrage, like, how dare they? Is there any, like, Japanese official who's, like, genuinely pissed, like, at a personal level? Or is it just sort of like grand institutional emotion? I'm also curious, what, what happens to a nuclear, a super dupe nuke? Super duper nuke? A super duper nuke. Does it get pressurized? How deep was the water 70 miles off? This is a great question. And Greenpeace had a lot to say about this. Okay. So when the Pentagon admitted this in 1989, they were actually responding to an article in Newsweek. And then Japanese papers picked up the story, which of course caused quite a stir throughout Japan itself, rightfully so. Though the Pentagon confirmed that the bomb would not be harmful, it hadn't been armed,
and you have to go through a whole bevy of procedural elements to actually arm it, it was still 16,000 feet underwater decaying, which meant it might eventually break down and start to emit serious pollutants. Yet, U.S. spokespersons claimed this wouldn't cause any harm to the natural world. Either way, it was safe to say they were in the hot seat, at least as hot as the nuclear material inside that bomb, shall we say. So while many were rightfully mad about the big Kerkrplunk, more were outraged because, in fact, the ship shouldn't have had the bomb on it in the first place. Yes, at the time of the incident, Japan had a ban on nuclear weapons. And there was apparently an unspoken agreement between the two world powers.
Japanese officials would intentionally not ask the U.S. ships what they were carrying, and the U.S. wouldn't volunteer any info either. It was one of those sort of like don't ask, don't tell kinds of situations. So what happened exactly? The incident fueled further questions about the use of nuclear weaponry in U.S. combat via diplomatic inquiry from Japan. It also called into question how we adhere to certain protocols and standards for safety, especially when it involves high-powered weapons.
and moving planes around aircraft carriers. Plus, you know, it solidified the longstanding tradition of lying to the American public. Since 1950, there have somehow been a whopping 32 broken arrow incidents. This includes theft. Wait, wait. Yeah, raising hands. What? 32 super duper nukeers.
Gone? Super duper nukeers. 32 lost nuclear weapons. Ooy, yoy. Now I know why they call. Call it broken arrows. Because when you say, you know what, we have 32 broken arrows. You're like, oh, if you say we have 32 lost nuclear weapons. You're like, wait, stop. What? Say again. Euphemisms make hard things a lot easier. Oh, man. Yeah. Yeah. 32. That's why Greg called all of our talking heads candy bags, you know. I forgot that. He said that he always felt bad giving us pages and pages of extra monologues. So he was like, I'll name them something fun. So he named him something fun. So he named him. I loved those. I loved doing those talking heads and like coming up with like new riffs and like
the candy bag, allts, like all the different versions of our talking heads. Like just it was like getting a window into the writer's brains. I just remember loving the math of those jokes and like always trying to think about how to heighten them and they'd have to kick me out of those talking heads. But to your point, naming all the extra work a candy bag. It's a trick. Definitely made it go down easier. And also, calling all our screw-ups bloopers makes them sound fun, too. Like, oh, that was a blooper. Like, that's just a broken arrow. I mean, even the word snafu is kind of fun.
It's a snafu. Guys, it's just a snafu. Oupsie. Whoopsy-doozy. Yeah. So these 32 broken arrow incidents include theft, accidental detonation, and just straight-up loss, like the one that rolled off the back of the. the taekondroga.
Like, yeah. I don't know, like, which one bothers me the most. I don't know if it's that we lost some, that they were stolen or accidentally detonated. Like, they're all three of those. I don't know which one's worse. I feel like theft is the scariest. Thest. Yeah.
I do too. But the next time you're feeling clumsy for dropping something, just remember that the U.S. Navy dropped an entire hydrogen bomb into the ocean and then kicked sand over it for 15 years. and they got away with it. So the lesson here, guys, is lie. If you mess up, lie about it. Because then 15 years will go by. That's the lesson.
That's the takeaway. Because then 15 years will go by. And then it's like nobody really gets in trouble. There's a little bit of saber rattling. And like people get like the like governments get mad and exchange sort of diplomatic, you know, zingers at each other. But it's not really like a thing. So yeah.
I guess that's the lesson. Do you think there are any other valuable lessons here, guys? I think there's a second part to that. It would be lie plus time. Give it time. Lie for a long time. Be patient with your lie. I think what you're saying is hold your lies deep inside of you for a really long time.
Hold those secrets. Not other people's secrets, your secrets. Hold them deep. Let them devour you from the inside. Such a positive message. I know. Snap. But in all seriousness, is there any, like, positive takeaway here?
Like, is there a way to frame this or look at this that, like, gives us a good lesson? Yeah. Thank you, Greenpeace. Amen. Thank you. I love it. Way to stand for something and hold people accountable. Like, thank goodness you're around because maybe we would have never known, right?
Because they seem like they were really sounding the alarm. on this. Yep. They were pissed. Yeah. About all this stuff. Yeah. They were pissed.
They were not going to let this just be swept under the rug. It is hard to believe, like, despite what the Pentagon said, it's like, it's hard to believe that a nuclear missile just decaying on the bottom of the ocean is like completely harmless. It's kind of hard to believe. It doesn't make any logical sense. I mean, what is that going to do to the ocean and the ecosystem around it? It's probably going to kill a couple of starfish. It's going to take out a few coral reefs.
I would also say that what is leaking there, I'm not saying it's this one nuke, but there are all these studies about what's in our fish. There's like all kinds of scary heavy metals in the fish. I mean, would you take a dirty penny and put it in a glass of water and let it sit overnight and then drink that glass of water the next day? You wouldn't. You wouldn't. I mean, come on. It's doing something down there. For sure.
Can I just bring us back? Bring us back. For a little callback here. I think instead of broken arrow, they should be called a dirty penny. Thank you, Angela. I like that. Got some dirty pennies to account for you guys. Yeah, that's right.
Now, tell me what you guys are up to and what we need to look out for you. What's next on office ladies? How many episodes have you done and how many are left, by the way? Well, we have watched every episode of the office. And we have given you all the behind the scenes, details, and trivia that we have collected from cast and crew members for every single episode. And we still have new episodes coming out every Wednesday. Amazing. We have our whole office rewatch library that is playing on Mondays.
And on Wednesdays, we have all new material, all new fun stuff. dive in deeper into the world of the office and our best friendship. It's super fun. Come hang out with us. Yeah, I'd love to. Are you kidding me? Jenna, tell them about your play. Tell me about your play. I am doing a play at the Goodman Theater in Chicago called Ashland Avenue. It's a world premiere written by Lee Kirk. You might have heard of him. Oh, yeah. My husband married to the writer, no big whoop. That's so cool. And starts previews on September 6th, and it opens on September 15th, and you can get tickets. at goodmantheater.org. I'm really excited. This will be my first time back on stage in about eight years. And, you know, theater is my first love. So I'm really excited. That is so cool, Jenna. I'm so excited
for you. Anne Lee, that is just awesome. Thank you. And this is the Goodman Theater's 100th year. So this is their centennial season and we'll be kicking it off with Ashland Avenue. No big deal. No big deal, though. And Angela, Angela's got some fun news as well. I do. So, you know, You know, Ed, my husband's a chef and a baker, and he's self-taught, and he's really big about getting the family in the kitchen and cooking together and baking together, and that the kitchen is the heart of our home, and he's been making recipes, and we've been cooking together for years now, and he's finally put all of our favorite family recipes into a cookbook. It's called You Can Make This, because that's what he says to me and the kids all the time.
He's like, you guys can make this. And you really can. And so we have that coming out in October of this year. And it's really great. It's a great, great cookbook. Congratulations. That's so, so cool. Thank you.
I'm excited to tell you about my book coming out in another year called Super Dooper Newker. Not true. Hey, you guys are the best. And I am just so, so happy to see you and hang out with you a little. little bit. Every time I get a chance to see you, it's just the best. Thanks for coming on. Oh, thanks for having us, Ed. You're awesome. We love you. Snapu is a production of I-Heart Podcasts and Snafu Media, a partnership between Film Nation Entertainment and Pacific Electric Picture Company. Our post-production studio is Gilded Audio.
Our executive producers are me, Ed Helms, Mike Falbo, Glenn Bazner, Andy Kim, Whitney Donaldson, and Dylan Fagan. This episode was produced, by Alyssa Martino and Tori Smith. Our video editor is Jared Smith, technical direction and engineering from Nick Dooley. Our creative executive is Brett Harris, logo and branding by The Collected Works, legal review from Dan Welsh,
Megan Halson, and Caroline Johnson. Special thanks to Isaac Dunham, Adam Horn, Lane Klein, and everyone at IHeart Podcasts, but especially Will Pearson, Kerry Lieberman, Nikki Eitor, Nathan Otoski, and Alex Corral. While I have you, don't forget to pick up a copy of my book, Snafu, the definitive guide to history's greatest screw-ups. It's available now from any book retailer.
Just go to snafu-dashbook.com. Thanks for listening and see you next week. I felt like I learned so much. I did not know how many broken arrows there had been. And I love Ed's podcast. This is its fourth season. It's just so great. It really is.
We love a deep dive. I love learning new things. And plus Ed is so charming. So it's a win-win. You know, he also wrote a book called Snafu, The Definitive Guide to History's Greatest Screw-Ups. It's a New York Times bestseller and here's a little blurb about it. Ed Helms brings you an absurdly entertaining look at history's biggest blunders, complete with lively illustrations. Well, we each have a copy and it's terrific. And we'll share a link to it in our stories. Well, thanks for listening, everyone. We'll see you next week as we break. break down episode six of the paper. See you next time. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.